[Music]
[Applause]
perspective
this 200 year old circus is fearing the
worst
closure the kovid 19 crisis has left
them
like many other venues and artists
struggling in the face of social
distancing measures
the creative sectors and the creative
industries
make up to 3.8 of the gdp of the
european union
and stands for more than 8 million jobs
is also important in the creative europe
sector
that we get an earmark in the recovery
plan for
the creative and cultural sector
during the pandemic the eu made state
aid rules more flexible
giving member states more scope to
support their artists and culture
but there's no dedicated eu recovery
plan for the creative sector
which is largely made up of
self-employed and freelance workers
with little or no access to social
benefits
on top of this the current seven-year
budget deal for the creative europe
program
is 13 less than what the commission
initially proposed in 2018.
meps are calling for targeted support
for the creative sector
to help artists and small cultural
organizations through the crisis
and safeguard europe's cultural
[Music]
[Applause]
landscape